[Musik]
ich habe strike bekommen also als wenn
zombie wargame kubaner als wenn alle
darauf schon der ganze server ist voll
wegen uns was soll das gezeigte aber
lava gameplay ausgeschnitten es ist
[Musik]
nicht zu mir kommt nicht zu mir ich ohne
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer neuen
folge war die heutige challenge von
dieser wahl folge ist es ihr seht schon
ich sitze hier in schale mit winterjacke
jedoch max face kam hier auf der anderen
seite eingeblendet er sitzt da auch in
schal in dicker jacke und mütze und
meine augenbrauen verschwinden wir
machen nämlich heute die winter
challenge das heißt wir müssen hier in
fetter winterjacke sitzen und ich würde
sagen wir schon jetzt einfach mal auf
den server weil seit 16 uhr ist wird
schon jetzt auf dem server meine damen
und herren ihr seht schon anmelden so
als wenn zombie moore game europa als
wenn alle hoffen dass inter wo bist du
denn ich bin offen server wurdest du wo
bist du magst max wo bist du
wie kann ich denn woanders sein als du
[Musik]
wo bist du druck auf f3 und sag mir
deinen koordinaten meines in 51 42 53 35
erwarte ich muss mir erst mal ganz kurz
hier was machen und eine spitzhacke ich
habe mich jetzt einfach eine wand ja
sagen ja wo du bist meine koordinaten
wurde noch in die gruppe gepostet max
hey ich möchte mich kurz aus dem schnitt
eben um euch zu sagen warum meine
koordinaten eigentlich gepostet wurden
ich sage das war im verlauf der
folgenden auf aber da ist immer so viel
anspannung dass ich das eigentlich gar
nicht richtig erklärt habe die spinnen
eigentlich glaube ich der einzige
derzeit noch in bar wo er seine folgen
halt wirklich so ein bisschen
aufwendiger schneidet also wirklich mit
hintergrundmusik angepasst mit passenden
geräuschen denn irgendwas passiert mit
einwendungen untertiteln et cetera ich
sehe wo videos von anderen teilnehmern
im projekt die riesige challandes haben
und sich nun ruhe geben mit ihren videos
dort und da ich halt schneide kann
deshalb nicht mehr passieren dass der
eine oder andere frame raus gekettet
wird und deswegen hat mir glp alten
streit gegeben weil ich in folge eins
glaube ich drei mal irgendwie 45
millisekunden aus versehen
rausgeschnitten habe es überhaupt kein
aufruf jetzt irgendwie zu helfen das
projekt zu kritisieren es ist halt
einfach so passiert ich muss es
akzeptieren und ich finde es auch gut
dass man oder so schräg hinter den
regeln steht aber das war auf jeden fall
der grund warum eine koordinaten
gepostet wurden also weil ich das
gameplay quasi manipuliert habe also es
sind risiken und ich habe nichts
verbotenes getan aber ich muss jetzt
damit leben und deswegen und meine
koordinaten preisgegeben
weiter gehts ja aber ich kann jetzt die
gruppe öffentlich muss nicken
warte ich muss mich weghaben oh mein
gott ist jemand bei dir
es sind so viele leute gerade auf den
server ich hätte nie gedacht dass welche
nach choina raten du bist locker über
mir hatte ich gerade statt einfach nur
bockig sagt jetzt meine koordinaten max
ok ja sagt sie sagt sie 400 690 50325 ok
ja wir waren doch beieinander ich hatte
ihnen die folgen nicht noch mal
angeschaut wo wir uns aus gelockt haben
ich war einfach unten in der höhle
bleibt genau da wo ein bisschen
funktionieren ich glaube ich den weg
hoch
die seite ist man ja aber mag es dann
kommen auch kommen ja ich mache ich doch
ich bin jetzt bei moment 500 wie ist
mein spitzhacke kaputt
soweit ich bin in der höhle bist du
schon oben
ich glaub ich gerade nach oben du siehst
ankoppeln weg max okay ich gehe jetzt an
die oberfläche ja wir müssen ja eh
abbauen
wir graben und beide unabhängig
voneinander quasi nach oben ja okay das
war eine ganz blöde idee ganz blöd ein
bisschen angst dass oben heute sind es
nicht die ganze zeit max
auch angst dass ihr welche kommen aber
man kann's liegen und spring
gleichzeitig na ja das auf jeden fall
okay gut ja leute also noch mal ganz
kurz zusammengefasst wie sogar zu viele
leute gesäumt sind max annahme dass bin
ich da darfst du oh mein gott oh mein
gott du bist du denn ich sehe ich warte
nicht mal ganz kurz
ok ich komm zu uns kommst du dir bleibt
da stehen macht bleibt da stehen ok oh
mein gott wir müssen endlich wieder
zufolge unter der erde machen gerade in
der letzten bild meine koordinaten
wurden veröffentlicht das heißt ich habe
ein strike das seht ihr auch schon dem
titel das hat man mir geschrieben weil
ich wohl irgendwie aus versehen in der
ersten folge ich finde selber ein
bisschen peinlich aber man muss
natürlich auch die regeln achten
ich habe in der ersten folge leider
irgendwie 1 2 millisekunden von dem
gameplay ausgeschnitten es ist der 10
nokia kommt nicht zu mir komme ich zu
mir auf keinen fall zu mir kommen ich
komme nicht zu demags
alter hast du dich nicht von der wand
gegraben marx alter ich habe ich auch ab
opa sechs morde in horw wieso sollte uns
in zehn mal nach weist die kunden leute
so geil darauf seien ein zu töten
okay ich bin jetzt unter der erde max
bitte entkommen bitte ich will nicht
dass es vorbei ist mit uns ich will es
auch nicht wo mein herz pocht er war
direkt vor mir zum glück hab ich mit f5
geschaut habe mich gesehen hat ich
dachte er hat dich gesehen und ist oder
wie alter leute dass es wieder
anspannung tor ich sag euch diese folgen
hiervon war wo sind die aller
spannendsten von uns glaube ich weil wir
immer verfolgt werden von irgendwelchen
blödmännern mich im moment ist gesehen
haben er muss es gesehen also mich hat
er auf jeden fall nicht gesehen bei mir
ist kein mensch ich habe mich auch
wieder ein bisschen in die ehrlich bin
daraufhin 55 ich glaube mich gerade
einfach nur weiter ich glaube jetzt
sogar falls jemand meinen weg finden
sollte gerade jetzt sogar so ein
bisschen in die saiten rein damit die
leute denken okay da ist da irgendwie
her gelaufen aber what the [ __ ] alter
wie um 16 uhr schlagartig gesamte server
volker junge es sind so sieben acht
leute geträumt nur weil unsere
koordinaten gezeigt palaver
ich bin fast den lava gefallen max alter
schwede
das ding ist ich habe jetzt gerade nicht
mal einen
eine spitzhacke und das ding ist
westermoor irgendwie auf die idee
gekommen ist weil wir uns das letzte mal
schon mit eisen folgen versteckt haben
ich hab's halt grad wieder gemacht dann
findet er mich gleich junge nummer
kurzum die story eben zu beenden
so schreibt er haider will das
irgendwann antwortet dass einnahmen
sieht
oh mein gott also noch mal ganz kurz um
die story zu beenden
wir ich habe mitbekommen
weil ich irgendwie millisekunden an
gameplay rausgeschnitten habe und
irgendwie wenn man halt ein streikrecht
werden halt die koordinaten von einem
veröffentlicht in der gruppe und wir
sind die koordinaten wurden
veröffentlicht um mitternacht oder sohn
der server war zu dem zeitpunkt offline
und max und ich haben uns gesagt okay am
nächsten tag um 16 uhr wenn der server
online macht wie scheunen direkt drauf
und wir hätten jetzt nie gedacht dass da
leute wirklich auch bis 16 uhr warten
nur um uns hinterher zu zeugen alter
und jetzt haben es trotzdem so viele
leute gemacht kick bei minusgraden an
server ist voll wegen uns was soll das
das turner gestern total viele
koordinaten gepostet
ach so das heißt gar nicht also nicht
nur wegen uns ich glaube nicht
also bei mir ist gerade in sneek riva
explodiert ich konnte hat mich ins
nicken und deshalb konnte ich nicht
vermeiden dass er explodiert aber ich
glaube ich bin im ort schon wieder
entkommen
es ist so unbeschreiblich junge muri
wenn du das siehst ist so verdammt
spannend lukas sollen wir jemals wieder
zusammenfinden
in der nächsten folge wenn wir uns
einfach gegenseitig die koordinaten ich
bin gerade wieder unter der erde ich bin
gerade auf höhe 43 wieder nein ich nehme
war obmann hubert gerufen
sebastian natürlich der tote die toten
hoch machen
ok meine spitzhacke ist gleich auch
kaputt das heißt ich muss dann auf jeden
fall kurz liegen aber ich bin noch 40
und ich sie irgendwo einen namen als
sicher dass sich jemand gerade meinen
weg zu er ist so unbeschreiblich krank
es ist so eine anspannung wir sind es
dann nur unter der erde aber diese
tatsache dass zehn leute oder noch mehr
gerade auf dem server sind und jeder
gerade bei uns sein könnte weil jeder
meine koordinaten hat locker das ding
bei mir ist ich bin muss mir jetzt eine
spitzhacke macht ansonsten komme ich ihn
niemals raus
bei mir ist es auch meine spitze ist
vielleicht auch kaputt
alter schwede ist es so fucking spannend
ich bin ich gerade da habe ich gerade
aim ist am morgen also es tut mir
wirklich leid ich will ich will ihn
nicht nicht beleidigen oder sowas aber
es ist halt so bitter ich war zwei mal
buchstäblich drei blöcke von ihm
entfernt bin jedes mal entkommen
max ich habe mich grad hingegen der
höhle eingebuddelt ich weiß nicht ob ich
die weiter lang laufen soll oder ob ich
mich im kreis gebuddelt habe sag mir mal
deinen cordes
warte ich muss mir eben der spitzhacke
machen oh mein gott walther tobi und
dehne auch noch okay ich glaube hier
slawen der nähe leuchtet ihr so also
allmählich langsam aber auch mal mit
leuten hier auf dem server es ist nicht
wahr leute der ganze server ist voll
es ist also das heißt er ganz das sind
natürlich locker noch mehr leute die
darauf schauen können aber es ist nur
noch krass gerade ich frag mich die
ganze zeit ob ich mich manchmal fragen
soll dann die höhe zu in die in die höhe
zu bauen
es bleibt auch nicht solche es ist so
mysteriös ausgeleuchtet hier als wäre
hier in polar war bei mir also ich würde
sagen ja ich würde sagen
das einzige was ich jetzt lohnt für uns
beide wir müssen wieder zusammenfinden
alleine haben wir schon mal gar keine
chance ist dass wir an die erdoberfläche
gehen
da würde ich überlege ob wir das nicht
lieber in der nächsten folge machen
sollten
oder noch besser ist wenn wir uns
unterirdisch finden sagte mir mal noch
mal seine koordinaten meine koordinaten
ja 530 43 auf der höhe bleibe ich auch
okay und 270 2 ok bei mir sind es 406
koordinate sonst wir uns relativ nahe
400er dann können uns ja entgegen laufen
ja also bei mir sind die koordinaten 526
und 412 ich komme jetzt erstmal auf eine
höhe
wie war deine letzte koordinator 270
meine letzte war 270 ja okay also ich
probiere mich mal in deine richtung zu
bauen
okay das will was heißen bei der ersten
koordinate 500 ok habe ich 530 bleibt
dann lass mal 515 gehen erstmal auf die
erste koordinate kommt nun auf 500 ich
gehe auf der anderen entgegen okay
machen wir so das müssen wir so schief
bauen
ich hoffe nur dass wir das hinkriegen
bis die vobis die folge sein dass ich
hatte echt gedacht wir sind tot als die
ganzen namen gesehen und wir hatten
gedacht okay allerhöchstens joint und
vielleicht ein team nach okay okay okay
ich habe mich in sehr eingegraben aber
seewasser sehe aber ich versuche mich
drum rum zu graben
auf jeden fall schon mal ein ort wo wir
raus können max es geht so langsam wie
man die koordinaten zu dass die leute
nicht irgendwie sehen können wo ich bin
ich habe den job meines lebens gab beim
ist amor gerade ich dachte so kämpfen
rennen war der neben dir
er war direkt neben mir ja also er hat
mich gesehen das war nicht mal ein block
zwischen uns
universe und die sind vor allem schon
früh dran also wir sind auch für iron
aber junge andere filmstar diamanten und
alles anders aber bei uns ist einfach
die größte spannung glaube ich schaffe
es wegzulaufen schaffen sind nicht bei
mir ist auch gerade wasser rein gekommen
wow alter was geht ab
einfach alles spannend da waren gerade
gerade moment
[Musik]
max welche koordinaten betreibe ich bin
meinem gleichen see bei dem du auch bist
ich bin bei ich habe erste koordinate
520 und die letzte 305 ich glaube wir
können bei den gleichen design
okkultismus an die oberfläche schwimmen
max ich bin ich hier in dem see bleibt
ronaldo schweden einstecken
bleibt doch unten
ja ich muss ja irgendwie nach oben
kommen jetzt wird ja nichts mehr rütteln
diese musste danach irgendwann gleich zu
essen damit ich regeneriere ich habe
nämlich auch kein essen mehr praxis
kommt hat extra in eine koordinaten die
ich habe mich die ganze zeit nur unter
der erde her
ich bin über der erde
und mir ist so heiß und gefährlich
gerade so unnormal aber es ist schon
voll war mit meiner wohnung alter
schwede
ich bin jetzt über irische du bist
überirdisch ja welche koordinaten 480
305 480 60 380 max um mich rum passiert
irgendwas wo bist du lauf bitte zu 513
313 max 13 313 ich muss dann aufhören zu
ich muss anfangen zu sprinten weil die
entweder maxi ist irgendwer
okay okay ich probier zu kommen hier
weiß irgendwer etwas von seinem essen ja
dann baulich hoch oder runter nicht
nicht stehen bleiben
[Musik]
auf keinen fall stehen bleiben hab
irgendwie
muss irgendwie an essen kommen
maxlive hierhin ich bin unterwegs man
wie viel gold ich habe anspannung wo ich
habe irgendwas gehört wie war es nochmal
513 5 120 113 5 513 520 503 10 320 junge
ich habe kein gutes gefühl bei der folge
ich auch nicht das ding ist ich muss
bald essen finden sonst sterbe ich
ich kann jetzt bald nicht mehr sprinten
wie weit kannst du dennoch weg sein ich
bin nicht gut darin nach koordinaten zu
laufen ok ich kann jetzt nicht mehr
springen ich muss jetzt erst mal finden
luca bei mir um mich herum explodiert
irgendwas hier sind leute ich glaub dir
ist ja aber ich seh da oben auch im
namen ich sehe da nahmen überall was
mach ich habe keine ahnung wie sie sind
bei mir sie sind bei mir luca und ich
wurde gekickt ich wurde auch geklickt
alter ich weiß nicht was wir jetzt
machen sollen bei dir max ich bin total
fertig bei mir sind überall leute vor
mir direkt auf einem offenen feld sind
ari und mister morgen alter leute ich
würde sagen wir werden jetzt mal die
folge ob wir die nächste folge überleben
seht ihr in der nächsten lassen wenn es
euch gefallen hat ich hau
alter was machen wir jetzt
leute ich bin gerade mega
ich hab gerade diese folge geschnitten
und bitte schaut euch zu 100 prozent die
morgige folge an das was morgen passiert
in der morgen in folge ich lege mich
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster ist noch
nie in irgendeiner waro staffel passiert
in allen folgen es hat noch nie so etwas
gegeben was morgen ist es hat viel zu
tun mit streiks es wird ein rauswurf aus
dem projekt passieren enorm viel morgen
17 uhr kommt der nächste part war
vielleicht der letzte